[Music]
well everyone
hello to the listeners out there
um we are if you if you've read the
title of the episode
you know what we're gonna tackle today
and he's a beast
he is somewhat beastly we do have to
establish some
ground rules though as to how many
impressions
sniffs and so on and so on each of us
are allowed to do for this episode
because it could get annoying i really
feel like we should be allowed
a generous number of them i would say
that only
one per person once oh
well i already used up mine then each
person can have one tick
like somebody can do on so on and so on
another person can do the sniff
uh then there can be the person like
yeah and
i can grab my shirt but no one can hear
that it'll sound like this
it's true so this is i i don't know when
we're releasing this
episode but it's very close to the same
time
that i'm releasing a video on ggek's
philosophy
and the reason for that was mainly that
you want views
mainly for clickbait
[Laughter]
no but i i needed i needed a video of a
philosopher that i already know
so i knew g jack because i had to do it
under a time crunch but
what i found looking up zizek
is that he's like cancelled
by a lot of people usually yeah
usually fancy people people who whine
about his decorum
the elites exactly it's the fancy the
fancy leftist poli-sci
bros that go to you know the ivy league
schools and now they're trying to make a
media career
out of it i wonder who that is and we
need some new enemies anyway we
i think we've beat the jordan peterson
horse to death so if we want
if we want to turn our iron elsewhere
one thing that's uncharacteristic in
some ways is that like the four of us
are all academics and we have somewhat
different backgrounds uh in like our
focuses but we all like zizek which i
think is maybe a little bit uh
uncommon perhaps these days in academia
he's the king
i don't know if i would say that but i
think we all we all have fondness
and weaknesses he's the one who made
theory cool for like this generation
yeah that's for sure yeah probably what
do you anticipate some of the criticisms
of hi
of his uh work is well i can actually
just give you a couple anecdotes about
mushi jack i have noticed him i mean my
department in the
political science department as you
mentioned i noticed that
theorists i've come across who i respect
uh have there have been multiple
instances where i've heard just
disparaging dismissive comments of zizek
made
obviously by people who didn't bother
reading them
and just saw him i heard one person
refer to him kind of disparagingly it's
like oh yeah i one
time went to go see jijek in one of his
comedy routines
and then um and then i heard another
person who was reading my dissertation
proposal where i do mention jijek
and uh you know i was just looking for
feedback not necessarily
um him to be on my committee but he kind
of mentioned he's like yeah like
you know this is an interesting topic
but uh the fact that you take zizek
seriously
means that we probably would have a lot
of diametrically opposed
uh commitments in theory
[Laughter]
that's interesting the fact that you
take g-jek seriously implied to that
person that you have
all of these views that you would
necessarily disagree with
yeah i know exactly like g-check it gets
accused of being racist
and sexist and anti-semitic
those are some of the big ones on the on
the probably on the
yeah canceling mean he gets critiqued
from both the left and the right i mean
it's interesting
the second professor i mentioned is
probably like a classical liberal like
like their their research is mostly on
like hume and stuff like that so that
maybe you would characterize that as
like a critique from
the right maybe or right of g but it's
true on the cancellation side
there is a lot of critique from the left
i think as well
yeah i think the article that we were
all dancing around is uh the october um
2019 article and current affairs what is
gjek4 uh that was written by
i think he's a phd at oxford uh
specialized in physics but
this article made a lot of waves because
it's just
lacerating he was a z-check of racism
obscurantism pretty much everything
under the book
um i think he tried at the end of that
to also like
put gg's arguments into formal logic
points and was very frustrated that he
couldn't and then
threw up his hands and said this is all
[ __ ] oh yeah it was a pretty clear
article
um i mean it actually provoked a
considerable response from g jack who
published uh
i think less than like two or three uh
reply essays in philosophical salon
to which the author of the speech
responded basically reiterating his
points
so it was some uh juicy leftist in
fighting
certainly yeah the current affairs
has been a host of some pretty dire
jesuit criticism
yeah well i can understand why i mean
like uh
i actually like nathan robinson i enjoy
his writing uh i think that he's wrong
about this
um and you know we can get into why but
having read a bunch of his articles on
this
he thinks that the kind of like hyper
academic
very referential super theoretical
approach that jesus takes
to radical advocacy is wrong uh he wants
things that are like more down to earth
grounded in people's material concerns
as they understand them
that kind of stuff i believe his
reference to zizek was
as an embarrassing clown of the left
yeah but no i don't take nathan robinson
also said that he was smarter than marx
and that people should read him instead
of
reading mark so i don't take him
seriously either with his little feather
cap willy wonka routine
he is a good writer i will say i read
his stuff pretty regularly on current
affairs and
he's very clear tends to be pretty
empirically driven uh
and it focuses on practical rather than
theoretical issues so i think this is
why people either love him or they hate
him uh but i can certainly see why he
would be
hostile to jesus since g-deck is kind of
the embodiment of everything that
he thinks leftists shouldn't be i think
robert robinson
i i actually really liked his art his
article i remember you linked it about
um
uh like like you know workers rights uh
in
in the context of cancel culture right
if you're if your job is able to fire
you the problem isn't necessarily with
you being canceled but with like the
your employer's
you know ability to just um fire you for
no reason
but yeah i mean i think that a lot of
leftists see jesus and they see that he
has kind of like
a weird view that isn't necessarily
linked to
what they would normally think of as
marxism and i think just don't really
understand him don't take the time
to actually read his philosophical
points um
[Music]
i am irate towards these
fancy fancy boy leftists especially and
probably because i'm from the styx
so my educational career has been able
to grind out a lot
of my um what would you call it the
sticks the rural tendencies we'll call
them too
the regular people yeah but then the
folks
the folksies but then the gatekeeping
suit wearing
trust fund yale iv oxbridge whatever
when those people gatekeep me or or
infantilize
or dismiss as clownish uh then i get my
back up
see actually i would tend to agree with
you on this uh and
i'll say why um i think you know one of
the interesting things is i think nathan
would actually turn this around and say
well this is exactly why he doesn't like
people like zizek right like gizek is
hard to understand unless you have like
a pretty firm education
um and you know a background in critical
theory and the history of like
continental philosophy and so on and so
forth um which is why in his mind we
should be focusing on things that
seem to have a more down-to-earth appeal
like advocating for universal health
care criticizing
people on the political right who are
popular authors and so on and so forth
i actually think that there are a lot of
people i know
including people from pretty rough
backgrounds who are interested in
philosophical issues and like to learn
about this stuff
and so i think he's misguided and
assuming that
we really should just be focusing on
more practical things because that's
what people are interested in because i
actually think that people are quite
interested
in the ideas that underlie a lot of
these positions right
and i think you can see that with
somebody like jordan peterson right i
mean jordan peterson has a huge fan base
um
from people from like all walks of life
in part because he
appeals to their interest in having an
intellectual justification for their
positions
and i imagine that gg fulfills a similar
role for those of us on the left
right and i think people are interested
in knowing about that
i would i would agree with that except
that it's hard to know what his
positions are
like you'd have to react quite a bit to
even even get to that point but anyway
we have an unstructured podcast always
unscrew
all not unstructured we'll say
unscripted and always unscripted
and some of us have a chip on our
shoulder when it comes to
let's call it the sanctimonious
dismissal as a hot take
own when you clearly don't even have a
[ __ ] clue what you're talking about
because as i see it this is in my
opinion a totally different set of
circumstances
than an academic disagreement like the
props you were talking about earlier
this is basically a battle of images
crazily dismissed
well well at least for willy wonka clout
is at stake
yeah and yes and it's fine it is an
image celebrity but there's also a long
uh not very careful but long career of
thinking
supplementing that image celebrity and
to
i guess to have the gall to hand wave it
away could only come from someone who is
pompous enough to say it would be better
if marx had never been born
oh my god that's not an academic debate
it's a claw for clout
for willy wonka well actually i i kind
of want to
like be a bit harsher towards actual
academics because i will say
you know getting into like academia
doing my phd being around whatever
like so-called top scholars i gotta say
i find it so i
found it very surprising the level to
which there's
you know lazy thinking and like lazy
dismissals for lazy reasons and i think
zizek is a prime example of somebody
who i often hear academics very you know
decorated academics just saying
dismissive things and i know that they
haven't read them
and i guess like i would say that the
biggest i would say that like the the
most valuable uh
tool i ever learned in academia was when
i was doing my masters
and i remember my supervisor at the time
on my master's thesis
we were it was on rawls and i was like
very dismissive of a lot of things rawls
had to say and
he really taught me this like super
valuable lesson that you know people who
who you initially don't like when you go
and read them like
if you have an attitude of charity
you're going to find that there's
something interesting that there's a
reason why people like them it's not
just
you know nonsense and i think it's a
it's a virtue as an academic
to adopt an attitude of assuming that
there's going to be something valuable
if if a thinker is very popular there's
got to be a reason for it
and it's on you to do the work to find
out why people like him
and i have to say it's shocking the
number of you know high-level academics
who don't
uh seem to have that virtue which is
like actually pretty obvious when you
think about it
i would be remiss if i didn't find out
that that in itself is a very
rosyan kind of idea when it comes to
interpreting philosophy
in his um lectures on political
philosophy that i've read right you
should always be as
generous as possible when interpreting a
figure you should always presume that
they're right
uh and then if they're wrong you know
you should try to strengthen the
argument to see if it can
hold water uh you know all that kind of
stuff but i agree there's some slow
reflexivity and i appreciate it but i'm
from i'm from the farm
and i [ __ ] hate smugness i mean
also from an academic perspective
like i'm at the i'm in i'm in the same
sort of stage too
building a uh building a um a
dissertation
around a bibliography and trying to come
up with a reading list
like i can't imagine the sorts of
reading lists that gek would be
a figure on when like
you you get your committee together and
you present them with your proposal
i mean you've already done your
comprehensive exams i guess and you have
this reading list
like what role does jijek play on the
reading list first of all like if we're
saying he
he often repeats himself and writes the
same book over and over again
okay so which book do you put on there
and then what's his role on your reading
list
is g-check just going to be a foil for
your own interpretation of marx or a
foil for your own interpretation of
hegel or lacan or whatever
like i can't see him contributing to
a a i guess a comprehensive exam list or
a bibliography
yeah for a monograph that you have to
present to get your phd
especially in a in a in an environment
where you might expect your supervisor
your committee members to already be
hostile towards gg's ideas
you can't put them on there as anything
more than a foil
or somebody to just contrast your ideas
with but not take seriously
not take seriously in like an academic
sense of the points you're gonna make
not
dismissal but right i was i was reading
less than nothing
like for this video uh rereading and
he quotes wikipedia yeah
oh i don't remember exactly it was like
the i think it was the wikipedia article
of a
movie so you know hopefully he's seen it
but
we don't know but i was in the wikipedia
article and he was like there must have
been a reason
for i don't think he's just doing it for
yeah no i think less than nothing
if you need one book that has all of
zizek in it it's probably
yeah that one i i would say that yeah
stephanie's magnum opus at this point um
but like i think just speaking to eric's
point i think one of the reasons why
people are a little bit reticent
uh to accept him as a serious academic
is precisely because his work is so
trans-disciplinary
right i mean take less than nothing
right uh i mean formally the book is
supposed to be
about synthesizing hegel on the phone
which is
an eminently academic task that anybody
could recognize like recognize right
but at the same time the book touches on
everything from politics and history and
then has a huge chapter on quantum
theory
which is really controversial right
since a lot of people are like what are
you doing talking about this
and virtual reality porn yeah exactly
well yeah of course
i mean with czech porn is a kind of a
must right but i think there are people
who are
reluctant to say that there's still a
place for that kind of systematic
philosophizing a la hegel right
precisely because they'll say well you
know the disciplines are separate for a
reason and it takes a long time to
become
skilled and adept and actually
understanding the kind of technical
implications of
this of that scientific theory so you
should you're probably better off just
not
engaging with that you know what i mean
my
thought really doesn't derive from his
work though or a judgment
of this work i think to be interesting
or to make philosophy and theory
interesting
you have to be a bit of a provocateur
and he fills that role exactly
perfectly so to that end i'll transition
to our second uh part of our structure
here
and that is to ask what is philosophy
for according to you guys i don't know
if you know what he says but
it's in uh
i think parallax view he pretty much
states philosophy
is to articulate problems
well which is quite different from
someone like uh de luz
or uh badu like for de liz philosophy is
about creating concepts so it's meant to
be a productive
enterprise and another reason that jijek
is chastised often
is for not being productive like what am
i supposed to do with this how do i
how does this benefit the left cause but
according to zizek himself that's not
what philosophy's for
and that's not what he's doing um as an
author so
i don't know uh sound off what you guys
think philosophy is for
and then maybe we can find out what is
g-check
for uh thanks to current affairs well i
remember him talking about
about that uh somewhere in one of his
talks you know he described he describes
philosophy as
i think he even said it's a very modest
task right it's not going to solve some
huge things it's just like you have to
get clear on what the issues are what
are the philosophical puzzles
state the question better you know like
what is like what is reality
i don't know the philosopher's job
should be to you know
interrogate the question but not
necessarily expect to find a solution to
that
question but like get clear on what we
even mean and i think
i i think that that's right i mean i
think i think philosophy i agree with
that definition
i do think philosophy is just about
is for asking those kinds of fundamental
questions and trying to get clarity on
them and trying to state them
in a in a clear way like but i suppose i
would say like you know you'd hope you
might get some
sort of answers from it but i think uh
it's true that
that at least um for those answers to be
anything worth anything at all i think
jijek's answer is important and correct
that you have to get clear on what the
problem is
before you before your answer is going
to be worth anything at all
and and it's true that most of the time
in reality philosophy
is and probably good philosophy would be
preoccupied
with uh with getting clear on what the
question is i think
and definitional and yeah i think
i i don't know if i could give it like a
definite answer
but i mean i that kind of definition of
like clarifying
issues like i mentioned like in the in
the michael brooks
uh tributes that are going on right now
and when cornell west
and g-jek were on they they pretty much
agreed
on the same sort of thing right like the
the role of philosophy is to clarify
questions for people so that they could
understand
or engage more effectively with issues
but i mean that that also has the sort
of lingering
idea of like the professionalization and
institutionalization of philosophy that
it's going to produce people who are
public intellectuals who have a
relatively one-way relationship with
their audience right like they're
talking to them
but they don't get talked back to very
much so they have a pedestal
and they have a voice and so in that
situation when you're a public
intellectual yes
you can clarify problems or what you
think are problems for people
but i think like from seeing the way
that fans react to this sort of material
like podcast fans fans of theory these
people are not
interested solely in like oh there's
problems in society what do i do i'm
gonna turn to podcasting
like they themselves are looking for a
more therapeutic
effect of philosophy on themselves and
their lives right like people
tend to like this sort of stuff because
they think it
it not clarifies issues that we have to
engage with in more effective ways but
that it
seems to bring i don't know things in
their personal experience with the world
into more relief
so it has a more i guess i'm saying it
has a more therapeutic than
a sort of social justice kind of effect
on a lot of people
and those are the sorts of people who
are not doing philosophy as a profession
they're not public intellectuals they
don't have a large audience with which
they have like sort of a one-way
communication relationship with
they are listening to this stuff and
reading this stuff because they think it
clarifies things about life and meaning
and purpose
and so again yeah they're more of a
therapeutic effect
and that's not i guess maybe totally the
answer but that's something that i'm
thinking about
i've dreamt somewhat differently uh
although i think that like uh victor and
eric both in on like
key aspects of his thought uh or
certainly there i see zuzia at least in
my interpretation uh as performing kind
of
denaturalizing unmasking um of our
interpretation of the world
uh and he articulates this very well
through a number of different metaphors
where he says one of the problems uh
with classical theories of ideology for
example
is that we assume that ideology is just
about
taking off our glasses to see the way
the world really is
right when actually we have to recognize
that the way that we see the world
is indelibly stamped uh with ideology
right
uh and various different naturalized
ways of thinking about things
um and so this is why philosophy has in
some sense an
ending task because its goal isn't to
try to tell you how the world really is
uh it's merely to kind of
break down or deconstruct uh or
dialectically
uh implode the various differently
over-determined way
the various different over-determined
ways uh that we try to conceive of
reality
uh and give it a kind of solidity and
naturalness
that isn't actually there and you find
this also when he
talks about his own ontological
preferences right where he says
virtually every kind of ontologist who's
ever written on the subject
assumes that reality has to be complete
perfect
and whole right whereas i'm saying
actually that reality
is a lot more like a pokemon game uh
which is one of my favorite metaphors he
gives
right uh because you know in a pokemon
game you're wandering around and
you assume that there has to be
something outside of the forest
uh that you're currently trapped in when
really there's nothing outside of the
forest right because nobody actually
bothered to put anything there
and the reason why he interprets this
ontologically is he says
i see reality as being fundamentally
some kind of catastrophe
right it's incomplete it's riven with
mistakes it has deep problems within it
and most of the history of western
philosophy has been some effort to try
to
explain away this incompleteness of the
world uh by suggesting that it
has a law like character or there's some
kind of imminent telos to existence that
we should all be beholden to
uh and so on and so on it is
it is definitely about this unmasking
and i think that's one of
the draws of like uh public
intellectuals as opposed to
academic intellectuals but i think it's
a product of this
probably like celebrity culture that we
feel like
you have to produce something that's
going to be effective
what are you doing for the cause and
whatever but
yeah my interest in philosophy has
nothing to do with that it's
more like i guess a ritual
like religion without religion almost
it's a a way to see
coherences to produce coherences
but really to feel less alone in the
world
and i know that sounds kind of like soy
to say but
but when you when you read someone that
is articulating the thing
that you are trying to
get a grip on that's really the reason
that i
think philosophy is important and and
zizek definitely is one of the
like his objects are cultural
objects it's it's starbucks it's
porn it's the batman movie it's titanic
and this is like the if you if you learn
to
i think people wish i mean i wish that i
was able to see
as much as he sees at every little
object and that's kind of why i admire
him
yeah i know i i agree with that a lot i
think
um what's what's interesting about zizek
and the way he's taken up or
his critique too is i think people see
him
uh you know commenting on the cultural
realm on the political realm and he does
it in a kind of like irreverent
amusing way and then he calls himself a
marxist
so then like marxists who are more
practical will like
but he'll say things that seem contrary
to marxism and he'll be like kind of a
buffoon
and they won't understand but they don't
but all these people don't actually go
bother read it to read
what his philosophical core is which is
i think the platform with which
he then makes the comments he makes
about culture
about uh about politics like so they
just see like the comments he's making
and the humor and the irreverence but a
lot of the time
and then they also see that he's not
being loyal to some marxist vision of
praxis
um but they don't actually bother to do
the work and then i think
his irreverence that he doesn't act like
a normal academic
puts another puts a a a brighter target
on his back i think and there's an
example of this that i can give real
quick
is the uh political correctness thing
because he's against political
correctness
people are upset that he's against
political correctness because
you know you don't care about the people
of color or whatever
but his reason for being against
political correctness is
very specifically lacanian because
lacana has this sort of dialectic too
where you have these encounters or
ruptures from a negative
and it kind of collapses your your
system
but then you have to rebuild around or
you have to rebuild the symbolic and the
symbolic is where you find all these
codes and then you get
something called a master signifier
which the khan calls it
and he just sees political correctness
as being the opposite of amounts of
emancipation because you rebuild
uh basically a speech code and so
there's a reason for why he says i don't
like political correctness
because it's against his project which
is ultimately to like annihilate the
subject or bring
subjective destitution so uh yeah
it's inflammatory but like you said it's
grounded somewhere it's not like he's
just
being reactionary and you can't you
can't make me call trans students by
their
preferred pronoun like peterson he's as
he's giving reasons
but yeah exactly yeah and like do you
think that his i'm curious what you all
you guys all think
because the humor aspect like i think
this is one of the things that makes
that makes jejuk unique right that he
and i wonder
like i've i've often wondered like
you know i think that his phil is his
philosophical insights
you know i do see him in a lot of ways
as a philosopher of like the fallible
human animal like like he's very focused
on like how fallible we are like that's
you know because a lot of his his his
interest is exploring like
the disconnections the the the
nothingness that's at the core of us
you know um the way we try to cover it
over uh with our desire and all these
things you know that this futile this
feud up futile kind of dialectic of
desire that we're all in
and i think there's a humor to that uh
you know i think there's a connection
that he sees he sees the absurdity
um and you know that things should be
laughed at i mean some of it i'm sure is
just a personal
like like a kind of personal character
trait that he has that he likes humor
but i do think it's compatible with his
philosophy but i think i've said it
before on it maybe on a different
episode or maybe it was
off the air but you know that i do think
this this kind of collides
with what i often see at many academics
as having a personality type that is
kind of like an aesthetic ideal
there is very much a kind of asceticism
with academics there's a seriousness
there's a smugness
with many of them there's like this care
that we have to be careful about
everything we're saying and
we have to be precise and i think
shizhak's kind of like well look at all
the
you know chaos that's inside of our
subjectivity already like this
this trying to be precise like what are
you doing why are you wasting your time
like you gotta laugh and you gotta just
say what's
on your mind like why are we pretending
that there's this you know this
tranquility uh or this
this um uh what's the word stability i
remember the movie exactly
he literally like his segment uh like
have you has anybody seen the movie
examine life the documentary yeah good
good one
it is yeah he's got a 10-minute segment
on there exactly but like almost every
other academic is in some like hyper
formal setting like martha nosebomb was
like walking along
the water uh i think it was like uh
yeah michael hart is like literally
rowing in the middle of central park
and jesuit just goes into a dump and i
was like
through the trash and like he finds a
porn magazine and he's like
you call this porn
double fisting hot dogs i was watching
it with my roommate at the time and he
was like
man if you didn't know any better like
knew who jesus was you think he was just
like some homeless guy like literally
rummaging through the crack
like beating off to like discarded porn
or something like that
but just like your point uh victor and
pills um
that he has a really good joke that
always i think
testifies i think too the kind of
analytical power behind the humor
because he uses this to make a point
against political correctness which is
what we were talking about before
where he says uh what's the worst hall
you can put a child through
uh it's telling your kid you have to go
to grandma's house
right because the kid doesn't want to go
to grandma's house he'd rather
stay at home playing his ps3 ps4 or ps5
right
and he says in classical
understandings of authority um the
patriarchal figure would just say
you have to go to grandma's house
there's no if and or buts about it
and this was obviously bad but on the
other hand you know at least authority
was overt you could know who the
oppressor was
uh you could try to resist it that way
and he said the problem with this new
political corrupt politically correct
plans authoritarianism
uh is they work subversively to change
your subjectivity uh so the example he
gives is
rather than your dad just saying you
have to go to grandma's uh your dad will
sit there and be like of course it's up
to you whether you want to go to see
grandmother
a grandma or not but you do know that
your grandmother is very sick and very
old
and she misses you so do whatever it is
you want and jesus is like this is well
the true horror comes in
because you are expected now not to just
go to grandma's but you want to go to
grammars you have to desire it
and you know and he says this is the
kind of attitude that you see with
political correctness but
no this is a much more radical form
of coercion it's a much more
authoritarian it's like a covert
authoritarianism because it doesn't just
prescribe your action but it prescribes
your subjective state you have to desire
you have to want
exactly it's a it's a kind of melodrama
thing he does
but it's it's always it's consistent
with the point he wants to make but it's
still kind of melodramatic
and that's what i love the other thing
with these jokes is that
they stick in your head they really mate
yeah they make theory
matter and they make theory not boring
which is pretty much the only goal of my
life at this point
a little more accessible than it might
have been before because like his big
thing is to be a popularizer of lacan
who is
one of the most difficult writers you
could possibly read
yeah gj's jokes yeah they are i'm
holding up that book yeah
they're helpful they're helpful and they
make it like i love his sensibilities
with those things like it's great
exactly like and whenever i think about
that joke i'm just reminded of like any
relation bad relationship i've been in
uh where like the girl sits there and
it's like no i know that you're doing
what i asked you to do but that's not
enough i need you to want to do what i
asked you to do right and just like
the sheer feeling of oppression that
comes from it right it's like a no fear
philosophy book come to life he's just
he's just funny he plays with concepts
he plays with ideas
and he's he's he's not shameless but
he's he's
irrepressibly funny in situations where
he shouldn't be but it's it's fine
because you know seriousness
and comedy are always like so close to
each other
i find that i have a sensibility where i
love comedy
more than drama or anything else that's
why g-jek appeals to me quite a bit
in his mannerisms his way of doing
philosophy
even if i don't agree with everything he
says i don't like i could go
to this philosophical level i don't
agree with him but otherwise
like his delivery and his overall
politics and
project is like i'm fine with it i have
no problem with it
but i think it's really useful though i
mean like i was trying to explain
ideology to a bunch of students right
and i played them this video where he's
talking about coke and he's like
do not remember that the slogan of
coca-cola back in the 1980s was
just this is it here we see ideology at
its purest right
well the signifier of the coke in
and of itself because almost a
transcendental
kind of quality where you invested with
all of your desires
and it is literally the be-all and
end-all of existence and like they were
watching that they're like i never
realized a commercial had so much
involved in it i'm like
hey [ __ ] neither did i but i'm never
gonna look at a coca-cola the same way
again
and it does do a really good job of
showing you how to use paul's term you
know
the symbolism of ideology and its kind
of determinancy
is saturated through uh the life world
right
uh that was a bad halloween german gj
costume
voice yeah yeah was that supposed to be
a shisha guy i thought it sounded like
a looney foreign freud yeah i don't
think we can get cancelled for this
though because it's you know
yeah anyway um well not to be the
authoritarian father but would you
all like to move into the section where
we talk about his philosophy
sure yeah i mean i was actually going to
say uh like why i find him useful for my
own work like his philosophical insights
i i think that fits in this section yeah
okay
well give it a go to figure out how to
do this because i
my videos are going to exp why don't i
summarize what my video is going to
explain
um yeah okay do that you've already
probably seen that but yeah we can like
take off from there so we don't repeat
yeah so yeah good idea i mean you start
with hegel and the important part of
hegel
is the dialectic um and
sublation or alpha bond the special word
where over
there's an overcoming and in this
uh progress there's always a development
so you're trying to develop
for hegel it's like history develops the
concept of freedom develops
and and you want to be more
self-determining because that's what
like freedom is
but the problem with this development
um that's always going forward uh
presumably i mean
that's kind of bad hegelianism to say
that because it doesn't always go
forward but
you know there's a movement a
progressive direction
and the reason that doesn't work all the
time for zizek is
what matt was talking about earlier
lacan
this like whole oh no sorry is victor
the hole in subjectivity
and all the contradictions in
subjectivity where we're just desiring
endlessly
so desire never has an end and
there's no free will in lacan there's no
like free will argument that could be
made
based on leukemia and philosophy because
you're just stuck forever
rebuilding the symbolic desiring forever
sad boohoo i was going to say that if we
are going to be talking about desire
and repressed desire especially this is
where i'm going to start hitting on eric
oh god like pretty consistently
right he's coming it doesn't feel very
repressed to me
can't help it we're bringing we're being
brought out of ourselves
jewish exactly right i mean beyond the
limits
all right so that was stage one and
stage two
but then um you need to return to hegel
you're gonna use lecon's what's called
the uh
what's it called the excess of desire or
the lack of the lack the less than
nothing
thing there's a little interminable
excess indivisible remainder
oh there you go that's it now based on
this
you refuse to be yourself
like christ did on the cross you're
abandoned by god there's nothing left
except that one little bit that is you
which is the nothing of a nothing
and you can use that as your freedom
to push into uh an uninhibited new
hegelian land of like a new
alfhebang but you're kind of outside of
history
and of course this gun this comes along
with all
of the sorry i said you're outside of
history
you're not determined by history you're
self-determined at that point
and then you just toss in all the
marxist stuff we know commodity
fetishism
ideology obviously an updated
altuzar version of ideology and then we
can have like an egalitarian future
with destroyed subjects that see
themselves as self-determining and free
instead of
as you know stuck in these loops
does he actually think that that's but
does does he actually think that it's
possible to
overcome that or just momentarily maybe
i think to be consistent they would be
moments of freedom but
the communist aspect of it or the
egalitarian classless
society is kind of the driving
force behind why we would want to become
free subjects
so capitalism obviously has to go he
does sometimes imply that love
can provide that kind of not ultimate uh
an unending but like
at least quasi-permanent uh
reconciliation
uh right where he says that the thing
about real love is that
false love the kind of love that you see
you know prevalent in the capital
society is one where
you value other individuals as objects
um so you only really value them
insofar as they gratify your desire uh
whereas true love of course comes from
recognizing this other person as
somebody who has fundamental flaws
and not loving them in spite of but in
part because of their flaws
since their flaws are determinative
right and when you get that kind of
recognition from
another person right who says i don't
just love you in spite of your flaws but
because of your flaws because that's
what you are
uh it provides that sense of completion
and fulfillment that we can't get and i
imagine
his conception of communism is meant to
politicize this
right yeah in terms of yeah universal
kind of love and recognition i think uh
i think that's right i think that's
consistent with
what i see as like the dj's main point
which is just like really dwelling in as
i said before the fallibilism of the
human animal and i think like
that's that makes sense to me because
like you're loving another human
because you're you're cognizant of all
the flaws and the way we're
constantly being tempted to like to lie
to ourselves to build these imaginary
symbolic structures that try to try to
reach some kind of
you know uh shiny like smooth wholeness
to give us that but like we're always
we're always falling into
this kind of conception in our mind that
is making it
feel like we've achieved this wholeness
but i think i always i've always read
shizuka saying that it's like impossible
to get away from that that that like you
know you can have moments maybe
but like you know that like love is just
a momentary
like like really recognizing you know
that those
real moments of love is kind of in those
moments not of
not when you have this you know um
like transcendent feeling of that is
like kind of intoxicating
but maybe it's actually in those moments
uh you know of seeing the flaws of like
the crisis but then you
still love in spite of all that because
like that's the rupture in your fantasy
of you know this person but yet you
still love even though you've been
exposed
to the horror underneath it but you
still love right so that's the moment so
it's not
so i would just hesitate to like or push
back against any sort of conception that
makes it seem like it's something that
resembles
like smooth you know harmony or
something like that it's really not it's
really like the moment of
it's being confronted with the horror
and then still kind
of um going beyond he even gives us some
nice materials twist where he says like
this is one of the reasons why
you see so many people who don't
actually genuinely love one another
right and it's precisely because they
dematerialize um the individual they're
supposed to be in a relationship
with uh and then they're horrified when
they found out that that individual has
a body uh with all the things we'd
associate with
uh and this is also kind of a testament
to like why the kind of jokes that he
makes are funny right because
he likes to make like [ __ ] jokes and
sweat jokes and sex jokes right
but all these re-emphasize the fact that
we're
embodied beings right uh that with
bodies that have
all kinds of flaws and disgusting
features uh and abnormalities and stuff
and being loved in part for having that
is what provides us with a sense of
security and completion
right um so really you know this is what
i think this is
pretty common sensible right i mean it's
why you tend to care
uh for somebody more uh when you know
they
carry you home because you're drunk or
you know they forgive you for
farting really loud in public or
whatever it happens to be
because you know they kind of
acknowledge that you have a body and
that it has its flaws and that
you have your weaknesses and it's they
care about you regardless
right uh whereas exactly like we see
dissociate from the body and try to have
this
ideal image of what we are dissociated
from all that right
yeah i think i think that a jazekian
view of love would would say that you
know all these
conventional ideas of like why we love
somebody you know like all these
idealizations
like that's really just a house of cards
that you're standing on like that's not
the thing those aren't the really the
things that are gonna be like love
yeah i'll just give an example from a
buddy of mine once uh where
he said that he can't he went walked in
once and he saw his girlfriend taking
his [ __ ]
uh and he said like i thought about it
for days afterwards and it just
profoundly bothered me because like
i knew that she must do that but like
seeing it happen
really really bothered me and i was like
well you know this is true love now
right like you share it like
in the intimate processes everybody has
to go through
and yeah now you can love her for now
you can love her for who she is
you know d transcendentalized as it were
as a material being
you know exactly exactly i mean this is
for me why i find jjx so important and
like you know maybe just
this is connected to just my love of
lacanian thought in general but i think
she
is like very useful for this is just for
me like my
my interest is you know political i'm in
a political theory department and
like for me my my interest is about you
know what like
is kind of trying to clarify the
question what does it mean to be
emancipated what does it mean to be
democratic or whatever and i find
uh zizek useful for you know really
dwelling on the fallibility and i guess
i find a lot of i find
um one of the things i find frustrating
and unconvincing and democratic theories
that come from the continental tradition
is
they will often take continental um
insights
that kind of uh unravel like the myth of
progress that they make things
contingent so therefore if everything's
contingent then anything's possible
but i always feel like there's another
move that needs to be made which is to
recognize
the fallibility and like the weakness
and the and like the reason why
you know we should try to limit our
expectations of the everything is
possible because other things are
contingent
and i think xiz is useful for thinking
about something like
um you know like how likely is it that
we're gonna you know develop
as you know democratic citizens who all
want to like work together and
deliberate on things
you know and like see each other for you
know
a valuable other citizen right this is
all to me really unconvincing stuff and
i feel like you need
someone like shizuka to is useful
politically for thinking about that
those kinds of
points of fallibility and the way these
kind of democratic dreams can be a bit
fantasmical
and maybe that's also why xiz comes into
conflict with other marxists perhaps
because there is this other aspect of
him
he's very much about de-sacralizing i
think
exactly exactly like destroying the
fantasy
destroying denobilizing and that's like
again i mean i don't want to
hate on political correctness but
because we already use the example
that's the thing that's like
compelling love but doing it through
coercion through a threat of punishment
versus a law
so that or or you just feel like you're
gonna guilt someone into doing it
because when you're guilting someone
then you're using their psyche against
them and their whole
you know father apparatus so the idea is
if we can get rid of
all of all coercion of all types
all ideology all fantasy then
it would take a brutal honesty but
that's the only way to
you know resurrect ourselves in a
christological metaphor
yeah it obviously makes them different
from other people who use psychoanalysis
too because obviously
like sexuality and love and and desire
is very central to
like psychoanalysis freud and lacan
but what makes him different is what
what pills was saying too is that he's
not
he's not using this to sort of sacrifice
like when
when uh when jordan peterson brings up
sex and love and marriage it's usually
to the sacred
union of the nuclear family and it's not
it's not he's not using it to poke fun
and he's definitely not using it all to
make these like larger philosophical
points like those are the things that we
need to
justify in his world whereas like
g x ideas is like oh the female orgasm
is
the new version of the ontological proof
of god he says
and he says instead of dismissing this
let's undermine it from the inside
yeah well i think there's a lot of moves
that jj likes to make like reversing
things right and i think you know if we
could also you know
use the term nobling ignoble
like there's a temptation to want to
know like make things like the family
and love and
you know establish them as these noble
ideals and
he's obviously trying to undermine that
but but beyond undermining that i think
what he's trying to identify with his
comments about love and all these other
things
is that the very nobility of those ideas
actually lies in the core of their
ignoble aspects like
so you locate like true love right in a
sense
in like the most ignoble instances the
things that are most embarrassing the
most
the the points that are most
crisis-laden and most
um you know embarrassing in our and are
revealing the flaws and
and fallibilities of the human being you
know that's the location so it's like
reversing it and really the egg noble
exists in all this fantasy and
and uh you know like imaginary symbolic
structure that we try to overlay all of
those things on that's where the ignoble
i think lies for him
maybe this is why he's so hated by the
professional
opinion havers because they
it exposes to them their own humanity in
a way that they find revolting
with their little facts with their
feather caps
they can't be self serious i think this
also applies to his interpretation of uh
reality itself though because i mean you
see a lot of these
uh affinities in the ways he thinks
about human subjectivity and the way he
thinks about nature predictably since
he's a galleon right because he says
think about the way that most of us have
tried to perceive nature it's almost
always been in this
highly reactionary way where we say that
nature is perfect
right uh nature is harmonious nature is
teleological
uh at its apex we did say nature is
basically conceived of created by and
ordered by god which makes it a divine
creation
uh and the only reason why anything bad
happens because humankind [ __ ] it up
right uh it's our fault like a russo
type view
exactly and jesus i think is actually
kind of refreshing by saying you know no
uh what does he say like nature is
catastrophe right you know
uh nature has kind of all all kinds of
weird idiosyncrasies and destructive
tendencies uh it's not sacred at all um
and so we shouldn't be all that
surprised when sometimes bad things
happen
uh and just like yeah well i mean this
goes back to
an episode we did on conspiracy theories
right because he says when you buy into
this reactionary vision of nature and
the world is harmonious except
when uh interfered with by human
activity you're very prone to thinking
in conspiratorial terms by saying wow
something bad happened
it can't be because nature is at fault
or it can't be because sometimes [ __ ]
just happens
uh it has to be because somebody's
responsible for it right somebody
disrupted the perfect harmony
uh whereas zuzia is kind of refreshing
by saying no sometimes catastrophe just
occurs
because in a lot of ways nature is
catastrophe right
and this kind of connects to his whole
critique of new ageism
and uh western buddhism as he likes to
call it
because we present these things as like
false
false re-sacralizing try to re-enchant
the world but doing it on like
very shaky grounds like the buddhism
or whatever western buddhism that we
have is
uh basically colonial a colonial product
taken from these places where they
wanted to make their religion seem more
appealing so that the christians
wouldn't just like wipe them out so they
said no
it's about nature it's not really a
religion it's just like a way of life
when no it's like it is a religion it's
a religion here here here and here and
then he tells that story about
the japanese buddhist monks that justify
uh war crimes in world war ii saying
like
no it's not actually you killing them
because it's the bullet the bullets
flying through the air
it enters their skin but it's not
actually murdering anybody because this
is just a natural process of material
interacting yeah i do think there's some
room to criticize him
on this point and i imagine eric would
want you though because he's sometimes
critical of the environmental movement
on this basis by saying that absolutely
we should care for the environment
but primarily for anthropocentric
reasons right that you know we need to
care for the environment because it
is material that we'll need in the
future but we should
at all points resist the temptation to
resacralize nature and say that
well nature was harmonious and my chair
was healthy
and the only problem is humanity's come
in here and kind of disrupted that with
its pollution
and so on and so forth an example he
usually gives to criticize
environmentalists is
uh the creation of oil right where he
says you know 800 million years ago oil
was created basically because the planet
exploded into a new volcanic age and
billions and billions of species died
and then their remains were compressed
into oil and you know that goes to show
you that
the idea that mankind is somehow
uniquely a disaster for the planet
uh is wrong right the planet has always
been a disaster
uh and we're not uniquely responsible
for the crises that are befalling it uh
even if we should manage them better
right and he calls that he almost he
calls that like a modern retelling of
the story of the fall
yeah it's fantastic but it's comforting
to think about
us coming here and ruining some harmony
it's like better it makes more sense
it's less you know it's less traumatic
to think about it that way because we're
the problem it's not just that nature
intrinsic to it is chaos and and like
and the potentiality of destruction
exactly and he says you know you can
watch movies like fern golly or avatar i
mean criticize after on this basis right
and it's always exactly this kind of
biblical metaphor right it's like nature
was perfect everyone lived in harmony
and then man arrived and man destroyed
everything by
building factories and waging war and
putting pollution into the environment
uh whereas his argument is
you know nature isn't all that it's
cracked up to be nature is pretty [ __ ]
up and useless and
a lot of garbage uh and so we shouldn't
be sacrilezing it even if we should be
trying to
tend to it better for human purposes so
he's very critical of
and for very specific contextual
pragmatic reasons we need to be like
correcting things right for very
specific
like kind of down to earth reasons as
opposed to like
some ideal of like an undisturbed nature
or whatever
exactly i just imagine that like if you
were a deep ecologist right you'd
probably take
serious issue with this right because
he's essentially calling you a
spiritualist right that you think that
there's some beauty to nature and some
imminent qualities to it
uh when really nature is just the dump
that in the movie
right it's a whole lot of nothing and of
course at the same time constantly talks
about how like
climate change is like is is a huge
threat right so like it's not like he's
some anti-climate change
person like he he knows it's like a huge
threat he acknowledges that it's
you know he talks about it as one of the
main potential future problems right he
talks about
like genetic stuff one of the like the
main points of crisis right like an
environmental so he's certainly not
you know some person who doesn't uh care
about the environment he just sees it he
thinks it needs to be conceptualized
in in a more precise way i suppose that
doesn't doesn't fall into this kind of
uh idealizing fantasy
yeah but that's why i like him right
like he has a unique take on the subject
matter because
usually like people who tend to be
environmentalists also tend to
uh implement explicitly or not adopt a
deep ecological view uh kind of like the
story of the fall that you were talking
about right that
yeah well i was going to say we see the
same kind of fantasy go on too like i i
i notice it with like indigenous
politics stuff i feel like you know
like like white critical theorists often
just like to think about indigenous
cultures if it's this hormone like
was this harmonious like peaceful you
know and totally ignores that yeah
actually indigenous people are human
beings just like the rest of us and they
had wars and they had like horror and
torture and all kinds of stuff too
well that's why jesus hated avatar right
because it embodied all those things
right
uh i had this a very uh nostalgic
uh and spiritualist dimension to it
where it's like oh there's this
beautiful planet and the people there
live in harmony
and then human beings come with
industrialization and modern energy and
everything falls to [ __ ] right
and he's like well no first off like
these are human communities or at least
anthropic communities
uh where people have all the problems uh
that they do back on earth
uh and secondly you know this planet is
just matter like anything else
it's not sacred or special in some way
shape or form
so people can use it to you know empower
themselves in some ways that's not
necessarily a bad thing as long as they
do so in responsible manner
right yeah i don't i don't disagree with
the things
i don't disagree with most of what g x
says
about like i i think he's a very he has
a very
measured like perspective on
environmentalism
and it's good and i think you should
always approach
environmentalism with the idea of
ideology
as like a lens because obviously
environmental groups
are pure ideological
assemblages as well right so you should
always approach them
with the idea that they have a system of
ideas
and beliefs and they're there there's no
necessity that those correspond to
anything in reality
like if you want to just win the game by
definition
then yeah no no modern systems biologist
no modern ecologist believes nature
is a harmonious system that's just not
that hasn't been a thing since
but that was a thing up until the 60s
right
up until the 60s everyone assumed that
everything like humans did to the
planet the planet would sort of correct
and absorb the problems and impact and
return to a state of sort of harmony
and now we regard all living systems as
far from equilibrium systems
they're they are pretty much the
definition of like
not in like a a pure state of
equilibrium would just be
like nothing like that total entropy no
exactly no order nothing it would just
be pure even distribution of all heat
and matter
right which is not obviously not a state
we're going for that's not what
environmentalism is shooting for
but you have to be aware that
environmental groups like greenpeace
and whatever the sierra club and all
those big environmental groups have
agendas
they have ideologies they have optics
and they're involved in politics so all
of those things means that g
jack's view of ideology critique
is going to be always an important thing
to consider
when you want to get into
environmentalism
and not just be like a naive realist
about the world
and greenhouse gases and the impact of
of nature on human affairs
if you're not going to do that then you
should listen to g jack
right he's he's really against any
sanctimonious
reasoning for anything even if it yeah
even if it's like the sanctimony
like for for a good reason so like
what's wrong with believing that
the planet is an interconnected whole
because at least we might take care of
it but he's
also going to say no you can't do it
that way
he does have a good reason for this
though and actually i think it was a
really clever observation that he made
uh because he says
one of the problems we're seeing nature
uh as kind of a harmonious hole
uh that we just tend to disrupt is we
have this sense that there's kind of an
inner purpose
or narrative to existence and this tends
to
play into our fantasy that somehow we're
uniquely special that we're here for a
reason
uh and that there's a divine or some
other power that's looking after us
which can of course be another reason
why we say well we don't need to worry
about climate change because just like
at the end of the movie how everything
winds up okay
uh because of some kind of natural
intervention we'll be fine
uh and jesus says no you know we're just
part of nature as well uh we're here
because of entirely contingent accidents
there's absolutely nothing special about
us
right uh it could very well be that will
be destroyed tomorrow
so you better [ __ ] wake up and
realize that there's not going to be
some at the 11th hour rescue
if you allow the planet to follow the
[ __ ] right uh if the planet falls to
[ __ ]
uh we're going to be wiped out with it
it reminds me of a george carlin joke
uh where carlton was like i hear
everybody talking about
the planet save the planet save the
planet the planet will be fine
the people are [ __ ] but the planet
will be fine
it'll carry out and like this is kind of
the essence of jesus environmentalism
right where he says
stop presuming that there's some kind of
inner purpose to nature or your own life
uh because that leads you to believe
that there's something special about you
which means the universe will
correct uh itself in order to save you
that's not the way things work
if you don't [ __ ] like take some
responsibility for what's going on
then our delicate ecosystem will be
destroyed and we'll be wiped out
yeah like yeah i always say like like
when we talk about the anthropocene for
example
as the like successor period of the
holocene
that comes with an ideology attached to
it right like it was
proposed in 2000 by some scientists but
the way that
it's been uptaken into media and the
humanities is that
anthropos means human and it's our fault
that we've done this to the planet kind
of thing and then
and then you have to ask about a series
of questions after that if you want to
be rigorous though you say well
like who's responsible who is it an
anthropocene for like whose fate
is really at stake here and then we ask
well like isn't it better called
something like jason moore calls it the
capital ocean
right like maybe we should point to
capitalism as
as a kind of dynamic force that's that's
changing our
human nature relationship
and the the whole the whole idea of the
deep ecology movement too right
it's it's been critiqued from within as
well and it comes with an ideology as
well
just like anthropocene deep ecology
right like that's that's
a norwegian guy named arm ness started
the deep ecology movement
and he based it quite heavily on his
reading of heidegger
yeah and so it promotes a kind of
localism right like
like withdraw from the global community
and get involved in local projects
you know farm your own food it's like
it's a real localism
and a lot of people today are going to
say well
you know we live in a globalized world
and
like obviously neoliberalism part of the
force behind that ideology is the global
trade
and economy how our economy and our
lives are completely
interconnected with the rest of the
world so is deep ecology
going to be an environmental movement
that's
going to be very helpful or successful
in the future probably not
because we need to take that sort of
globalist element into account
and that's yeah so you always have to
take like g jack's
gex points seriously about these things
even if you don't agree with them
yeah and my disagreements tend to lie
more in his sort of metaphysics and his
his ideas about nature and ontology
rather than
in these sorts of cash outs on the
public facing end about what he says
about environmentalism i don't
have as much a problem with what he says
is as maybe sometimes where it's coming
from
and how i'd frame it but otherwise it's
usually very sound
and you shouldn't disregard it can i
just say that you know this is a
millennial podcast because
i can't think of any single philosopher
that we've discussed
we're all in unison that we like the guy
pretty much for like
that's true it's true pretty much every
single one of us was like yeah great you
know
but it's a very helpful dude to disagree
with he's very happy he is he's helpful
he's helpful for a lot of things and
like i i wanted to bring up you know
like just emphasize the point and
shifted a little bit to politics because
i think
um he he's so good on
pointing to and this is probably why he
makes enemies on the left because
i think his whole philosophical system
right everything we've been talking
about also
like of kind of calling out these
fantasies right works really well he's
he's pretty merciless in criticizing i
think when the occupy movement was
happening right he was pretty merciless
and
kind of being like what now and then you
know he talks about i remember that at a
talk once he was
saying you know i always talk to these
activists you know and they're like oh
fifty thousand people at tyree or square
and for oh we and and at sing toga
square and we were all
you know so ecstatic and so and he's
like i'm not impressed by that at all
you know he's like this
this kind of and he's so good at
criticizing you know the
the the ecstatic moments of political
mobilization
and he's always pushing i think
activists and being like okay so you
have your little ecstatic moment but
like what now
like what next and that's where he makes
the point about you know v for vendetta
how he wants to see he said
he would sell his mother into slavery to
cv for vendetta too
which is like you know after so they get
they burn down parliament they get there
they're all there so what now how do you
organize things what are the
what are the actual steps you take like
how what kind of political system are
you going to build
like he did say he had this hilarious
little monologue about this that
actually wasn't keeping with my own
experience about a lot of the occupy
people in toronto
where he was like i went there and i
asked him like what do you want
what do you want then and he would say
like well then they would give me like
those stupid platitudes like blah blah
blah
blah like money should work for people
and he's like and my god you know hitler
would have agreed with something like
that
but i mean it is true and i think we all
have that kind of dissatisfaction
sometimes with left-wing politics
where i mean i made this joke last week
right everybody says we need a more
radical kind of politics and
radical almost always seems to be just a
throwaway term
uh for basically saying i don't know
what exactly i want to achieve but it
has to be different than this but j-jack
is so good at revealing at like you know
um kind of exposing that so much of this
more radical alternative with his kind
of like lacanian and hegelian like
underpinnings
how like he can connect it and that's
maybe why people are hostile towards
them to being like oh you're actually
like enjoying like you're there's like
chewy sons happening here like you're
loving this aesthetic
this ecstatic fantasy and you're kind of
having a little mental orgasm thinking
about a more radical alternative and he
kind of sticks it in people's faces i
think that
yeah the perfect um theoretical
word for all of those things that he's
tearing down because
you're not allowed to have any sacred
cows
and that's kind of why he attacks so
much so many
different things through jokes often
it's not like a
it's not like he's just [ __ ] on
everything but he always is able to
point out here's your sacred cow here's
why it's wrong
or here's the history of it or here is
it in context or what do you do next
it's always pushing against or or
tearing down those uh
resacralizations which is funny because
he
i think he is really a secularist
christian
yeah his philosophy is
or a materialist christian i should say
it's a materialist
christianity and he says the like for
him the most important
moment in christianity is not like
christ dying but christ being abandoned
by god that's that's the moment he
points to as like
this is the destitution of the subject
this is when even
god falls we have no idols left now what
do we do and that's the moment of
uh you know liberation the final the
final step into hegel that's a stage in
the transition when willem dafoe's on
the cross and he's
looking around at everybody he's not in
pain he's not registering anything
anymore he's just kind of looking around
with a blank stare
i'm actually really happy you mentioned
that because that's my favorite
christian movie
uh eric last temptation of christ by
martin scorsese
it's that like almost that absolute
recoil moment where you just sort of
you just completely separate and then
like he has i don't know i'm tempted to
just bring anything you know you
traverse the fantasy you
you you get you get to the revolutionary
consciousness through
that like moment of subjectivity yes
can i just clarify clarify too quickly
about joey sons too i don't think that
he's like against
jewish sons right like or like people
experiencing it i think he just wants
those things to happen
responsibly in a way right like i think
he's just pointing to how easy it is for
subjectivity to be like get like
caught in caught up in these cycles and
like not move beyond so i think like you
know
so it's not like you know just i'm just
worried i don't want people to think
you know that he's some kind of uh you
know uh has some sort of aesthetic ideal
that you just have to be like you know
contemplative all the time and be
thinking beyond those things no no like
life has to be enjoyed i mean you have
to have
yeah sounds more you just understand
what they are and you have to understand
what's underneath them and like
yeah just to make just to make like the
important theoretical point
about jewish sons is that because jewish
sons is
that kind of idea of desire
transgressing some kind of boundary
but for for for gg like desire
is is non-sensuous in a way in the same
way that
kant thinks of of reason or rationality
is non-sensuous right like
does for kant desire is sort of a
sensuous desire and we have to get rid
of that
we have to become disinterested and we
have to submit to
like reason whereas zizek would say with
lacan that desire also has that
non-sensuous
aspect of it too so when you encounter
something
that short circuits reason like the
sublime for example right
sublimity the mathematical and the
dynamical right the
the large or the forces of nature that
that dwarf your capacity to understand
those things
and desire actually follows the same
pattern
whereas kant wants to sort of relegate
it to
sensuousness and the body for zizek
it's it's also part of the sort of
transcendental
fabric of our subjectivity too that
desire is also a kind of non-sensuous
thing so when you encounter the
mathematical sublime where
something is so large and then reason
sort of steps in
that's the sort of thing when desire is
frustrated the sort of pure desire
the ideas of the pure desire step in and
and
drive you in certain directions and they
and that's the sort of transgressing
aspect of jewish songs it follows the
sublime in certain ways
well just to kind of play off of
victor's political point uh
i actually think that one of the really
virtuous things about
jesus approach is precisely how he
desuplimates so much of the world
as opposed to put it like knocks down
our sacred cows or de-sacralizes them
one after another
uh because if you think about like the
origins of modern conservatism
in edmund burke right evan burke's first
book was on
the sublime and the beautiful and that
distinction and there's a clear
political implication
to this book where burke essentially
says look
some things are just too big for the
human mind to apprehend
uh and they fill us with dread and a
sense of impotence
and so we should be acquiescent towards
them defer to them
as it were and it brings up a lot of
religious examples uh
and there's a clear connection between
that and burst conservatism right
there's this idea that
the human mind is too small to ever
apprehend society
in all of its complexities so we should
be cautious and incremental in changing
anything if at all and what genic does
that's really spectacular is just say
no you know most things aren't
particularly sublime in fact a lot of
the things that we
supplement uh are just like the emperor
and the fable right they have no clothes
once you kind of strip them uh of their
ideological veneer you realize that
they're just as human uh or just as
fallible
as everything else and consequently
you'll be less willing to
defer uh to them as a source of
authority
or a source of signification right
and you know he brings up a lot of funny
examples about totalitarians right
and precisely how totalitarian and
authoritarian figures like nazis try to
sublimate themselves uh into these
incredible figures
uh when really if you deconstruct them
you realize they're quite comical
at their face in a benyaminian sense of
the word right
and that's part of g x sort of
self-image too
is he he he always he loves talking
about stalin because
because stalin was the perfect example
of
a kind of ideology where it has to take
itself seriously
yeah like at its center it knows it's
not serious like it knows it's not
legitimate
like when stalin goes out there
surrounded by bodyguards
like carefully kept away from the common
person and says this is the workers
party like they know
it's not serious but their ideology runs
on that denial
so so if anybody sort of talks in a
public way about how it's not serious
they'll be executed
yeah well wasn't this great at
reshuffling those elements too sorry
what were you going to say
i was just going to say isn't there a
joke or like an anecdote he has about um
how if you were like in whatever the
council the stalinist like
ussr like parliament or whatever and you
know somebody gets up and starts
criticizing stalin and saying like
you're a murderer and you've done all
these things
but then if somebody else gets up and
says how dare you say those things about
him
jiji claims that guy who called out the
guy would get killed first
before the actual guy who who criticized
the party because you have to keep up
the illusion
that you can have free discussion that's
like more important
yeah right then then like than the guy
solidarity
and again that's kind of why we need
that to to maintain that pure
uh contradiction philosophically that's
why he keeps
lacan or reads hegel through the khan
because the khan speaks to these
true contradictions or we believe
something exactly
knowing that it's false
and then act like we believe it anyway
and then we think that exactly no they
did this in soviet russia but this
happens
this is american capitalism this is like
starbucks like i'm gonna
i'm gonna buy um ethically ground coffee
so one percent of my
four dollar cappuccino goes to i don't
know
a bolivian child or something you know
fair trade whatever yeah
like his reversals and the ways he he
kind of reshuffles all the elements of
what he's talking about too because then
yeah you have this situation where
stalin you can't really joke about him
publicly
but he's like say perfect material for
south park or something like that
because he takes himself so seriously
and then you have this situation in
america where the south park guys like
refuse to make episodes about
donald trump because he's already like
his own joke he's already the butt
of everything he says and we we all feel
like he projects taking himself
seriously but he probably doesn't take
himself seriously and even our
even our funniest writers of political
commentary
just don't touch him because he's just a
joke already in his being and he
sort of reshuffles that idea of
stalinism and the and the
the lack of comedy but everyone's sort
of privately making jokes and but the
jokes are
show that you love him isn't this
exactly precisely why like academics
maybe like
priestly ascetic academics hate him
because he just is focused on
you know that nothing should be taken
seriously and like i don't know i think
a lot of uh
you know uptight academics i think
they're defined by seriousness you know
we don't have time to use philosophy we
need to have
a revolution well that's not academics
those are leftist magazine right yeah
magazine writers do not say we don't
have time to philosophize
um about this because you know we have
to take care of the cause and workers
rights or whatever
yeah yeah and then the academics are
taking themselves totally seriously
because they think that they're like
reinterpretation of
i don't know can't antinomies is like
world changing
and everybody needs to read this book
immediately
i think actually one of the most uh
lacerating political critiques he ever
gave a major figure was actually his
critique of heidegger
uh who appropriately enough he called
the philosopher without a sense of humor
right
yeah uh and he pointed out that
heidegger embodies a lot of
everything that we're talking about
right uh really took himself incredibly
seriously right like wanted to speak
with the voice of a prophet
uh you know capital you know talked
about big b
being uh in kind of divine terms
re-sacralize the world in a certain
sense
uh and then wound up of course
supporting all kinds of reactionary
views
uh and be kind of a ninja poop uh if you
think about it politically
right and the criticism of heidegger
really works
uh in part because it operates in all
these levels
right uh he's criticizing highgary and
metaphysics he's criticizing heidegger's
personality
uh but he also says you know one of the
things that's most problematic about
heidegger is
this kind of really oceantentious sense
of self-importance where he says the
history of the western world is
essentially
the story of its metaphysics which of
course puts
philosophy uh at center stage
right uh when really like the whole
history uh
of all these nations all the people who
made them up is really just dispute
between philosophers
uh and i find it really refreshing that
jesus says you know how silly is that
right to assume that
really you know publishing you know a
paper on chris earl's phenomenology
etc etc is vastly more important than
the tectonic events that impact millions
of people
out there right i mean how stupid do you
have to be to think that
this is really what matters right
yeah do you think that probably the
reason that we are kind of
drawn to him and maybe our generation
is drawn to him is because of this uh
profound opposition to
sanctimonious people that are
you know um i don't know
dreams that we don't believe anymore or
that we can't believe they look they
look too stupid to us
so i don't know guys like i think um
i was actually thinking about it more
just like the four of us that maybe we
we have a compatible personality type
that we all find him
we all see eye to eye on on these like
issues and kind of a
a hostility towards sanctimonious as you
put it
because i feel maybe it's different in
in the departments in the academic
departments uh you guys were in but
in my department like with political
theorists i would i'm probably the only
one who likes shijak
of anybody that i you know come across
probably i mean
there might be like one person who likes
them but most of them might have like
some affection but kind of vague and
they don't really know they don't really
take them they don't bother paying
attention
you know they kind of listen to what
their professors have said about not
taking him seriously i think he's
i hate to say it but i think shizhakin
is developing
a reputation in in certain departments
to just be like one of those clownish
academics you don't need to take
seriously which
is a real shame and a a real mistake of
course that we all
i'm sure would agree and what's funny is
way before youtube was a thing
like his book sublime objective ideology
was like praised and everyone thought it
was the new thing in psychoanalysis
if you buy anthologies from that time um
sublime objective ideology is always in
it i don't know if they still are
but like it's it's like his image
overcame his academic reputation
when he definitely had in the 90s
academic reputation before people saw
you know the baggy sweat stained shirts
and
he touches his face a lot but that is
almost like a cruel irony that proves
his point is like
they found out that this guy wasn't
you know a buttoned up suit feather cat
uh academic sitting in front of a
bookshelf he was like
uh walking down the street double
fisting hot dogs or whatever
so he he proves that he kind of proves
his own point by doing that i mean
there's
we're praising him only of course and he
does reuse his own quotations
all the time he's he's yeah he's sucks
at writing like factually yeah um
but yeah so it's not like everything's
good but i think we're we're kind of
responding to
the project as a whole as something
favorably
i actually met my my wife when we were
um
lecture right it was a three-day thing
and i was shocked because he
two weeks sorry yeah uh he gave this
little story where he was like
this is the thing like i was seriously
thinking about killing myself which was
kind of shocking to hear him say that
right because like
as it would be with anybody right and
he's like i was thinking about killing
myself and i went to talk to like my
psychoanalyst and like
i was like i'm going to kill myself this
week and he said my second house turned
to me and was like no you can't do that
you've already paid for the next two
sessions
and i paused and i was like she's right
i'm not gonna let her like cheap
like grip me out of this money so i
showed up for the next two sessions
and then at the end of like the first
one she was like make sure you pay me
more
uh so i did and then i realized like
well i'm not gonna let her grip me out
of like a few more sessions i'm gonna
stay alive
just to show up for these things and i
was like he's got a good sense of humor
about himself right like that's kind of
a very dark story
about yourself but he managed to be very
relatable he's
very transparent about how embarrassed
he is that his own appearance at his own
like he
he talks about how those movies he was
in right the perfect scout cinema and
the perfect guide to ideology in an
interview i saw
like someone was like oh have you seen
them like what do you think and he's
like it's impossible he's like i can't
look at myself he's like the trauma is
too
the horror and the trauma is too great
to just look at myself i can't stand it
yeah yeah it's it's nice that he can
combine that level of
hilarity with saying pretty fairly
profound and
cogent things and you know what he's
really nice like
he was a nice guy i mean i met him only
once but
like he's willing to just talk to
anybody about what they want to talk to
even though he's
trying to be ushered into a car because
he's late to get to the airport
just like having chats with people uh
it's impossible to get a word in though
like i don't think we could ever yeah he
just talks
endlessly oh but if you wanted to come
we should just have him come just to
talk
all right i'll just i'll sit here we'll
have like a skeleton crew and we'll
we'll uh ask him some questions
yeah that that would be pretty cool but
yeah i mean like it seems to me like we
all really like the guy and
i know i think like uh pills was kind of
right maybe it's a generational thing
because
when i started reading theory his books
were very very popular and only became
more so over time but i also do think
it's kind of an attitudinal
issue maybe he's what we want a boomer
to be
yeah it really fits with our kind of
independent
media get it out of the university make
stuff
widely available for free kind of idea
because
most people know him from youtube not
from his books i mean one example that i
saw
uh people talking about was uh his
debate with jordan peterson just to
bring daddy back for
two seconds right because people
expected that this was going to be like
a heavyweight boxing match
right where you had like the lead
philosopher on the political right
however you want to characterize
uh you know uh peterson versus like the
lead philosopher
on the clinical left and the thing is
peterson does speak with as like an
authority figure quite deliberately
sometimes
right where you know he has this
authoritative
almost prophetic uh kind of rhetoric
that surrounds him or at least did
uh prior to 2020 right uh and when zizik
appeared
and was kind of congenial kind of funny
a bit laid back wasn't taking it too
seriously people were initially
disappointed
but one of the things i think is
interesting is that over time more more
people seem to have conceded that he won
that debate
and i think one of the reasons is
because he refused to be
an authority figure right he more or
less pointed out the problems with
peterson as an authority figure
uh and the kind of associated
difficulties with that and said hey
listen i'm just here for you
to to provoke you to
be more critical and ask questions about
things uh and people were inspired by
that and thought it was insightful
right uh and a lot of them did and
that's one of the reasons that i think
he's popular
right uh he refuses the mantle that a
lot of people have tried to shove onto
him
he's the youtube philosopher
and i mean that in a positive sense not
a negative sense
yeah all right shall we uh wrap it up
there
yeah that sounds good yeah sounds good
all right i'll see you guys
i don't know when i'll see you guys well
hopefully they'll be uh that video i'm
looking forward to that new video of
hillary yeah i gotta
bust my ass to get it done so that's
what i'm gonna be doing for the next
five days straight
should be spicy thanks guys see you matt
air
[Music]
victoria
[Music]
you